brought to you by disney and pixar's
lightyear you know his name
[Music]
now discover his story only in theaters
june 17th
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
one there was a big swirly dude i think
i need a better oh no please record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle
greetings fellow cinephiles i'm nikki
novak and welcome to a very special
episode of rt essentials one might even
call it courageous that's because we're
running down some of the greatest heroes
in pixar's 25 film history whether
flying solo as a duo or even as entire
families these characters have risen to
extreme challenges displaying bravery
and often thrusting themselves into
harm's way for the greater good or
simply to help a friend in need they've
pushed us to the edge of our seats
they've made us laugh and yes
cause some light sobbing too
okay find some very heavy sobbing hey up
i'm talking to you directly
and though a list of animated disney
heroes could go on to infinity see what
i did there and beyond you see what i
did there we're going to stick with just
pixar characters today plenty of
incredible material there to work with
so without further ado these are our
selections for the greatest disney pixar
heroes
where's my cape
woody and buzz toy story i alone have
information that reveals this weapon's
only weakness and you my friend are
responsible for delaying my rendezvous
star command
who better to start with than woody and
buzz the heroes of pixar's first ever
feature-length release toy story though
the two share an incomparable bond one
that is only strengthened throughout the
four film franchise they weren't always
simplastico
woody was andy davis's favorite toy with
his pole string catchphrases and cowboy
getup but his position was jeopardized
when andy received the flashy new toy
buzz lightyear a space ranger superhero
at first woody felt threatened by buzz's
likeability going as far as trying to
knock buzz behind the desk but
accidentally pushing him out of an open
window in the process woody wasn't
toying around but the two were soon
forced to set aside their differences
when they got separated from andy at
pizza planet and ended up in the hands
of andy's malicious toy torturing
neighbor sid phillips it was in this
moment that woody and buzz's collective
bravery were first put to the test and
working together they managed to pull
off a dangerous escape
[Music]
[Music]
hey buzz you're flying this isn't flying
this is falling with style this pattern
of courageousness would continue in the
following movies like in toy story 2
when buzz and company sneak into an
airport and ride a labyrinth of baggage
conveyor belts in order to rescue woody
buzz hops from suitcase to suitcase
until he comes upon the one that holds
woody and then he flips open the
suitcase and is met with a sucker punch
from the pull string antagonist stinky
pete that's when woody shouts hey no one
does that to my friend and wrestles
stinky pete to the ground
stinky pete puts up a fight but he is no
match for the collective power of buzz
woody and their plastic peers
buzz risked his life for woody and woody
did the same for buzz and this would
happen many more times in the franchise
the cowboy and the space ranger
certainly came a long way since the
window incident you know what else has
come a long way
wondering for 27 years where our beloved
space ranger gets all his theatrics
charm and heroism from because trust me
it is not the equinox in beverly hills
and i have tried well if you ever
pondered the same thing get ready to
space out because disney and pixar's
light year is coming in light speed to a
theater near you this june ready captain
light you ready as i'll ever be
commander hawthorne this is exciting a
new adventure light year is a spin-off
of the toy story films and serves as an
origin story for the character of buzz
from whom the toy is based on we'll
follow buzz on a time traveling quest to
return home when a test flight goes
wrong leaving him marooned on a hostile
planet sucks how long have we gone yum
yum yum yum yum 62 years 7 months and
five days
what and as he tries to fix the mistake
that got him and his crew there in the
first place you know like heroes do
you know his name the probability of
survival with an inexperienced crew is
38.2 percent now discover his story
only in theaters june 17th
the incredibles the incredibles
do something don't just stand there i
need you to interred you want me to
intervene okay
[Applause]
these next heroes need no introduction
i'd say their movie title does a pretty
good job of summarizing i'm of course
talking about the pars family from the
2004 film the incredibles there's bob
aka mr incredible helen aka elastigirl
and then their eldest child violet the
second child dash and their infant son
jack jack each family member possesses a
specific superhuman ability bob is crazy
strong helen can stretch her body like
rubber so can i by the way
violet can generate impact resistant
force fields dash is lightning fast and
little jack jack well besides being cute
he might actually be the most powerful
one of them all he can teleport shoot
laser beams from his eyes and manipulate
objects with his mind he's a jedi
despite their many differences and
apparent dysfunction
when the going gets tough it's family
first like that scene where a giant
omnidroid attacks the pars on the
streets of metroville for those
unfamiliar with omnidroids they're giant
robots that have been programmed with an
artificial intelligence that allows them
to learn as they fight opponents and
solve problems as they arrive they were
created by the film's main antagonist
syndrome with the sole purpose of
killing superheroes specifically mr
incredible
a remote
a remote that controls what
the robot
as bob and helen share a sentimental
exchange violet screams and an omnidroid
comes crashing down using its grappling
claws to destroy everything and everyone
in sight
right away violet employs a force field
to protect her brother dash from being
crushed but the omnidroid breaks through
and knocks violet to the ground just
before the angry bot squashes violet and
dash bob interjects using his super
strength to keep the bot at bay while
helen stretches her arms and pulls
violet and dash to safety in a matter of
seconds each family member puts their
own lives in danger and utilize their
powers to save a loved one with the help
of an ally named frozone aka lucius best
the pars eventually defeat the omnidroid
and prove their collective bravery once
again of course a whole new set of
challenges would arise in the
incredibles 2 which was released in
2018.
mike and sully monsters inc i see you
please try to understand
not all monsters are malicious in fact
james p sullivan aka sully and mike
wazowski from monsters inc are pretty
stand-up guys yeah they spend a solid
chunk of their time terrorizing children
but that doesn't mean they aren't chock
full of personality and likable
attributes
sully is a furry bear gentle giant and
the one-eyed mic is a sharp-witted
natural leader but the real reason
they've been granted a spot on this list
of pixar greats is because of their
propensity to be
very courageous or more simply to save a
toddler named boo like they do in the
first monsters inc film released in
2001. boo had snuck into the monsters
inc factory through an activated door
and was discovered by randall an
eight-legged purple lizard also mike and
sully's rival
you've been number one for too long
sullivan now your time is up
and don't worry i'll take good care of
the kid no
randall and waternoose the spider-like
ceo of monsters inc intended to use the
scream extractor on boo a mechanical
device that does exactly what it sounds
like collects screams by this time sully
has grown attached to boo so he wasn't
going to just sit back and let randall
and water news do any harm to her sully
finds his way back to the factory and
breaks the scream extractor just in the
nick of time subduing randall and water
noose and freeing boo as sully makes a
run for it boon hand randall uses his
power invisibility to attack sully from
every angle sully takes a serious
beating but then runs into mike who
ignorant of randall's onslaught
expresses to sully that the two of them
are a team and nothing is more important
than their friendship mike even throws a
snowball exposing randall who takes a
solid punch from sully which sends him
sliding to the ground allowing sully
mike and boo to make their escape this
wouldn't be the only time mike and sully
flex their super heroic muscles a
prequel entitled monsters university was
released in 2013 featuring numerous
moments just like this one
carl and russell up
hi mr frederickson it's me russell what
are you doing out here kid all right get
your tissues ready folks it's time to
talk about carl and russell the main two
characters from the 2009 film up
co-written and directed by the great
pete doctor carl is an elderly widower
who had made a promise to his wife ellie
before she tragically fell ill and
passed away that promise to travel to
south america and build a house that
overlooks paradise falls when carl is
labeled a menace to society after
accidentally striking a construction
worker he decides to keep ellie's
promise by tying thousands of balloons
to his house and creating a makeshift
airship that he can fly to south america
this is where russell comes into play
russell is an eight-year-old boy who had
visited carl in hopes to earn his final
merit badge by helping the elderly
russell becomes an accidental stowaway
and before carl can get rid of him and
send him home a storm hits and they're
propelled far far away
now when you get up there
go ahead and hoist me up
got it
you on the porch yet
though carl may not seem to possess the
typical characteristics of a hero you'd
be foolish to underestimate him while on
this journey a fierce pack of dogs led
by a doberman pinscher lead carl russell
and their new golden retriever friend
doug to charles muntz an explorer who
has been driven mad by his pursuit of a
giant bird named kevin okay i know it
all sounds ridiculous
but this is pixar so we can suspend or
just believe for just a little bit just
for the sake of adventure anyway all of
this culminates in a scene where carl
must battle months in order to save
kevin the two elderly men exchange blows
muntz swinging his fancy sword at carl
who strikes back with his tennis ball
capped kane carl manages to get away
from months and lead kevin up the side
ladder of munster's swing blimp
thousands of feet up it's a dangerous
mission and carl doesn't relent until
kevin is safe and they can return to
save russell as well
nemo finding nemo the meeting has
officially come to order let us all say
the pledge
if i am to change this image i must
first change myself fish are friends not
food except stinking dolphins finding
nemo is pixar's fifth full-length film
and features the heroic titular
clownfish nemo nemo gets separated from
his father marlin when he swims too
close to the water's surface and gets
caught by a diver all while trying to
prove himself now marlin must set out to
find his son along with the help of a
blue reef fish named dory though
marlon's bravery is apparent fighting
off sharks jellyfish and a myriad of
ocean dangers it's nemo's actions that
prove to be worthy of commendation so
much of this film is predicated on
nemo's own journey to independence and
his father's fears of letting his son be
his own person or fish as i should say
so which one is it i'm from the ocean ah
the ocean the ocean
he hasn't been decontaminated yet
jacques
clean
ocean
voila
[Music]
it takes a crazy unfortunate series of
events for nemo to be given the
opportunity to rise up and reveal his
true character and his biggest challenge
of all is presented in this one
nail-biting scene towards the end of the
film nemo finally reunites with his
father after an arduous adventure but
just as we're ready to shed those happy
tears and rejoicing of the movie end
dory gets trapped in a fishing net with
a giant school of groupers as dory is
pulled up towards the giant vessel nemo
doesn't hesitate to swim down after her
despite marlin shouting with disapproval
nemo squeezes into the net with dory and
instructs all the fishies to swim down
but marlon is rightfully terrified to
lose nemo again this is when nemo looks
his father in the eyes and assures him
i can do this to which marlin replies
you're right i know you can
it's in that moment we see nemo's true
bravery and the climax of his character
arc he's no longer the scared little
fish that his father can't let out of
his sight he's now a hero with lifetimes
of experience and knowledge
marlon nemo dory and the groupers
managed to snap the fishing net off the
boat and break free swimming to safety
i know i'm not crying you're crying i
actually am myself chill saying that i
was pretty good
joy and sadness
inside out do you ever look at someone
and wonder what is going on inside their
head did you guys pick up on that sure
did something's wrong we're going to
find out what's happening but we'll need
support signal the
husband inside out was released in 2015
and tells the story of riley an 11 year
old midwestern girl whose life gets
turned upside down when she and her
parents move to san francisco her five
major emotions are personified and
throughout this life-changing event we
get to know the next courageous
characters on our list joy and sadness
joy is the main emotion that lives
inside riley endlessly happy and filled
with energy she keeps the team of
emotions moving along with her optimism
and lightheartedness
sadness is the deuteragonist the
depressive voice of reason that is often
led by angst you are my map
let's go lead on mind map show me where
we're going okay only
i'm too sad to walk just give me a few
hours
joy and sadness may be opposites but
that doesn't mean they aren't equally
important and the two learn to work
together for riley's well-being in the
headquarters of riley's mind joy loses
control of the operation and sadness is
m.i.a this leaves fear anger and disgust
at the helm as a result riley builds
resentment and lashes out at her parents
but joy won't just sit back and let
things continue in this way and in one
scene toward the film's end she
aggressively pursues sadness and brings
her back to headquarters at first
sadness flees and insists that riley is
better off without her but joy manages
to capture sadness and bring her back
where she belongs give her take some
speed bumps the two work the console
together creating new core memories for
riley and inspiring her to accept her
new life in san francisco
wally wally
next up is wally the titular character
from pixar's ninth feature film set in
the year 2805
wally is short for waste allocation load
lifter earth class and he's the very
last of his kind spending his days
diligently cleaning up garbage on the
uninhabitable deserted earth he's not
your average lusterless robot and during
his 700 years on the planet he's
developed a pretty adorable personality
befriending a cockroach named hal and
falling madly in love with a sleek robot
named eve aside from his loneliness and
curiosity wally seemed content with
carrying out his simple task for their
foreseeable future but his love for eve
would bring him on an unimaginable
journey through space and ultimately
lead him to one
very heroic moment when he sacrifices
his own life to save a plant the symbol
that earth can sustain life once again
and humanity can recolonize wall-e
understands the significance of getting
this plant into the hollow detector
which automatically will cause the axiom
to hyper-jump back to earth
no
[Applause]
[Music]
the axiom is a spaceship that hosts the
overindulgent human population and it's
controlled by otto an evil robotic
autopilot as otto fights the human
captain mccree for control over the ship
wall-e uses his body to stop the hollow
detector from permanently sealing and
buys time for eve and the humans to
retrieve the plant and put it where it
belongs
mccree motivated by wally's courage
musters the energy to defeat otto and
the plant makes its way back onto the
hollow detector but wali is
unfortunately still crushed in the
process the ultimate sacrifice from the
little robot that could but don't worry
guys this one has a happy ending
merida brave well that's just grandma
isn't it
i am merida and i'll be shooting for my
own hands
what are you doing you can't name a
movie brave and not feature at least one
heroic character this time it's merida
the first ever disney princess created
by pixar that was my best sean connery
impression merida is the 16 year old
scottish daughter of queen eleanor and
king fergus and the eldest sister of
harris hubert and hamish she is
headstrong and free-spirited and
challenges the expectations set forth by
her powerful parents
merida is a skilled archer possibly one
of the most skilled in her kingdom and
mix that with her sword fighting prowess
and we've got a legend in the making
it's no surprise that when her mother
was in danger merida doesn't hesitate to
risk her own life to save her but the
scene i'm referring to isn't so
straightforward yes see
a witch cast a spell on merida's mother
eleanor and turned her into a black bear
as you do and merida's father king
furious just happens to be a bear hunter
fergus mistakes his wife eleanor for the
sinister antagonist bear mordu and along
with his clan of soldiers captures
eleanor and plans to kill her with
eleanor the bear tied up fergus
approaches raising his sword high above
his head and striking down with extreme
force but he is no match for his
daughter merida who deflects his sword
jumps off her galloping horse raises her
trusted bow and arrow and demands get
back that's my mother of course fergus
is pretty confused at this point so he
pushes merida out of the way and once
again attempts to strike the bear
eleanor his wife meredith doesn't quit
and goes sort of sword with her father
slicing his foot knocking him to the
ground you go girl it was an impressive
display of courage but short-lived
because the real mordu shows up
immediately after i suggest you watch
brave to see what happens next
i can't bear to spoil it
arlo the good dinosaur
calm down
breathe
[Music]
sometimes you gotta get through your
fear to see the beauty on the other side
the good dinosaur was released in 2015
and tells the story of arlo an 11 year
old apatosaurus who lives with his
parents and siblings he's a sweetheart
with one major problem he's afraid of
well everything i know not very dinosaur
or like but as we've seen with the other
films on this list sometimes an
extraordinary situation can bring out
the best in a character for arlo this
extraordinary circumstance arises after
he falls into a river and finds himself
swept for hundreds of miles away from
his home and family for the first time
in his life arlo must face his fears and
braved the harsh wilderness
this is fury he protects me from the
creatures that crawl in the night
this is destructor she protects me from
mosquitoes
this is dream crusher he protects me
from having unrealistic goals it's
during this journey that he develops an
unlikely relationship with a human boy
named spot who really believes in arlo
and rightfully so because in one fell
swoop and in one scene arlo proves that
he's not the fear-ridden sauropod
everybody believes him to be and he
saves his friend spot spot had found
himself cornered by a group of
carnivorous pterodactyls on the bank of
a river
clinging to a tree stump arlo here spots
cries for help and races over charging
and knocking a couple of the winged
enemies into the water but then they
gang up on arlo who uses all his might
to fight them off while also making sure
spot is safe arlo lets out a mighty roar
allowing spock to jump up and bite his
assailant just when things are looking
up a landslide crashes into the river
and causes a giant wave arlo leaps into
the water to rescue spot as the two
helplessly fall down a steep waterfall
arlo then drags spot to the shore and
anxiously holds on to his friend until
he awakens arlo went from being
terrified of everything to risking his
life for a friend he is in fact
a good dinosaur
joe gardner seoul 22 has been at the u
seminar for quite some time and has had
such notable mentors as gandhi abraham
lincoln and mother teresa
i made her cry ignore that
we're truly glad to have you here dr
bobinson
[Music]
and last but certainly not least on this
list is joe gardner from 2020 soul
pixar's first film to feature a black
lead joe is a middle school band teacher
whose life hasn't exactly gone the way
he expected it would
his passion for jazz knows no bounds and
he's an excellent musician but
desperately needs to catch a break like
so many of us
unfortunately just as joe's big break
seems to be happening he falls down a
manhole and finds himself as a soul
heading into the great beyond joe had
come so close to fulfilling his dream
and he isn't willing to die so he tries
to escape but finds himself in the great
before which is where unborn souls match
with mentor souls to prepare them for
life this is when joe meets 22 and is
mistaken for her mentor joe is tasked
with helping 22 find her spark the
passion she needs to complete her badge
and finally start to live your spark
isn't your purpose
that last box fills in when you're ready
to come live
and the thing is
you're pretty great at jazzing
toward the end of the film after joe
realizes he's failed 22 he ventures back
into the zone to find her which he
eventually does
only 22 is now a lost soul bound by the
harsh cynicism that has been drilled
into her by many mentors including joe
himself joe manages to connect with 22
using a maple seed to remind her of the
wonderful experiences she had on earth
these actions restore 22 to normal and
she is escorted out of the grape before
and back to earth joe accepted that by
doing this he was forfeiting his own
life
and would have to venture to the great
beyond fortunately his good deed was
recognized and joe was granted another
shot at living and there you have it our
selections for the greatest disney pixar
heroes of course we couldn't include
every pixar character they're all heroes
in my heart they all belong on this list
but listen there's plenty more episodes
of rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll eventually get there thanks
again for tuning in i'm nikki novak and
remember if you need a hero this summer
catch disney and pixar's a light year
only in theaters june 17.
[Music]
[Music]
you